die große frage in deutschland ist
allerdings geimpft oder nicht das ist
unser großes thema und eins ist klar
unser land wäre ein anderer ort ohne ihn
ohne sein unternehmen in seine forschung
seine impfung die rede ist von bayer und
ex-chef sahin meine kollegin kyra
ortmann ist jetzt im gespräch mit dem
band t gründer
ja und er ist jetzt bei mir unser corona
hält der bandgründer ugur sahin her
scheint erstmal vielen dank dass sie
sich noch die zeit für uns nehmen sie
haben heute ein neues großprojekt hier
vorgestellt die nachhaltige
impfstoffproduktion in afrika warum ist
das so besonders dass die pandemie vor
zwei jahren losging da haben wir
festgestellt dass die welt darauf nicht
vorbereitet ist und eines der großen
hürden ist dass das die
impfstoffproduktion das nicht
ausreichend kapazitäten für die
impfstoff produktion da sind und dass
davon besonders die länder leiden müssen
die kaum eine impfstoffproduktion
regional gewährleisten können daher war
eines der zielsetzung die wir sofort
nachdem wir wussten dass wir einen
impfstoff haben haben wir uns mit der
frage beschäftigt wie können wir
sicherstellen dass impfstoffproduktion
auch in afrika aufgebaut werden kann und
zwar in einer modernen art und weise so
dass qualität gewährleistet ist jetzt
stehen wir hier quasi vor so einem
container den sie jetzt auch in afrika
aufbauen würden normalerweise produziert
man impfstoffe in einer fabrik die
mehrere hundert millionen euro kostet
was sind das jetzt hierfür kosten womit
rechnen sie also wir können die kosten
noch nicht absehen aber die kosten
werden deutlich niedriger sein als eine
als eine versteckte jetzt aus stein und
metall zu bauen was wir gemacht haben
ist in den letzten zwölf monaten unseren
produktionsprozess den wir hier in
marburg haben der ja in einer ganz
normalen produktionseinheit stattfindet
den haben wir unter skaliert sodass wir
dass wir die volumina reduziert haben
aber im grunde auf die gleiche art und
weise den impfstoff herstellen können
dazu hat passend haben wir auch geräte
identifiziert und und dadurch die
möglichkeit geschaffen dass wegen einer
containerlösung produkt dieser container
hier besteht aus sechs containern einer
dieser container ist für die produktion
von energie gedacht da stehen die geräte
drin die weiteren container sind die
vorbereitungsräume und klima wollen die
sicherstellen dass auch ein rein rein
luft in dem container vorliegt und
dementsprechend weil das wirklich iso
container sind kann man diese dieser
city auseinanderbauen auf schiffe züge
oder flugzeuge
transportieren und am standort wieder
aufbauen ist es denn so dass nur corona
impfstoffe dort hergestellt werden
können oder auch andere das ist die das
ist der große vorteil von mhh dass wir
dass wir unabhängig von von von der
impfstoff klasse produzieren können
unsere zielsetzung ist zunächst einmal
würde ich mit einem corona impfstoff
anzufangen aber wir entwickeln momentan
auf weitere impfstoffe zum beispiel
gegen tuberkulose gegen malaria wie und
wann diese projekte erfolgreich sein
sollten könnten sie genauso mit gewissen
prozessanpassungen auch in diesen in
diesen containern produziert wird wenn
wir jetzt einmal mit dem blick auf
deutschland auf die kuranlage hier in
deutschland blicken omikron ist immer
noch sehr präsent
wann kommt endlich eine micro mit
impfstoff wir haben ja vor einigen
wochen kommuniziert dass wir dass wir
einen impfstoff arbeiten wir haben dazu
jetzt erste experimente gemacht die
klinische studie läuft sie hat vor zwei
wochen begonnen wir erwarten die ersten
daten aus diesen klinischen stunden in
circa drei bis vier wochen und wir haben
uns darauf eingestellt wie wir das auch
in sozial kommuniziert dass wir
prinzipiell in der lage wären ende märz
an oregon in stoff auszuliefern aber nur
dann wenn natürlich auch auch die
regulatorische erlaubnis dazu vorliegt
wir sind im dialog mit den ausnahmen
mittelbehörden hier in europa mit der
ema in den usa mit heftig mit der fce
und basierend darauf was wir daten
benötigt werden wird das wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr ende märz werden sondern
verschiebt sich wahrscheinlich im april
mal lohnt sich das denn überhaupt noch
wir haben gestern exklusiv bei bild
verkündet das ende märz ja auch schon
die korona maßnahmen fallen sollen dass
es ein freedom der in deutschland geben
soll wenn dann erst der neue impfstoff
kommt also wir müssen die die
infektiologie uns angucken dann wenn die
welle stopp bedeutet das ja nicht dass
das das sie dann dass sie dann nicht
wieder beginnen kann es ist jahreszeiten
abhängig wir müssen uns erstmal
überblick verschaffen wie viele wie viel
prozent der bevölkerung tatsächlich
mit nikon infiziert worden sind wir
müssen sehen ob der neue impfstoff
besser ist als der existierende um gegen
ohne grund zu schützen hat die dritte
frage die wir beantworten müssen ist ob
eine micon impfstoff auch gegen
existierender varianten wirksam sein
kann und diese daten generieren wir und
dann können wir können wir tatsächlich
beantworten ob sich eine nikon impfstoff
jetzt noch in den in den nächsten
monaten wird die ist denn das zu beginn
der kubakrise beziehungsweise als sie
endlich den impfstoff auf den markt
gebracht haben weil es ja wirklich so
der erste lichtblick den wir in dieser
ganzen corona krise gehabt haben und
jetzt das war vor einem jahr und jetzt
ist corona immer noch thema kuba ist
immer noch vorbei nicht vorbei eben
nicht vorbei sind sie auch ein bisschen
enttäuscht davon dass es nicht ganz
unerwartet also im grunde im grunde geht
es ja beim impfstoff vor allen dingen
darum auf der einen seite zu versuchen
die welle die wellen zu stoppen das
haben wir sehr erfolgreich gemacht gegen
den ging das bild virus und auch gegen
das delta virus aber das zweite und das
wichtigere ist ist die sterblichkeit zu
reduzieren wir wissen dass diese
impfstoffe an die sterblichkeit gegen
den originären virus reduziert haben
dass sie die sterblichkeit gegen gegen
delta reduziert haben und dass sie auch
die sterblichkeit jetzt bionicon
reduziert und das ist das wichtigste das
heißt die welle hat er hat hat nicht
mehr den schrecken wir haben der
infektion den schrecken genommen und wir
fangen jetzt an mit dem corona virus zu
leben das ist das was wir erwartet haben
werden niemals erwartet dass wir dieses
corona virus loswerden das heißt auch
die nächsten 15 jahre müssen uns darauf
einstellen aber es wird aus unserer
sicht nicht nur dieses große drama sein
was glauben sie denn
wann wann kann man wirklich sagen kroner
ist vorbei wann würden sie persönlich
sagen wo oma ist vorbei
das ist schwierig also ich glaube wir
müssen uns auch darauf einstellen dass
wir
zu gewissen zeiten weniger über corinna
sprechen und so sodann wieder eine neue
welle redet kommt mehr über über corona
sprechen das wird das wird einfach
einfach nicht zu vermeiden sein wir
werden immer wieder ausbrüche haben
wichtig ist dass wir uns darauf
einstellen und eine gewisse routine uns
erarbeiten wie wir damit umgehen umgehen
wollen und das passiert schon ich glaube
der großteil der bevölkerung weiß ganz
genau was als nächstes kommt und wir
können uns jetzt darauf einstellen und
was notwendig können wir auch neue
varianten impfstoffe herstellen also ich
sehe die situation wirklich nicht mehr
dramatisch das ist ja schon mal wirklich
ein positiver ich bin glauben sie denn
dass es in zukunft noch wieder andere
krankheiten geben wird also das ist dass
vor allen dingen bald schon wieder geben
wird oder kann man das überhaupt schon
sagen das können wir nicht sagen es ist
es ist es ist es ist auch vorstellbar
dass bevor corona weg ist jetzt wieder
ein neuer erreger auf uns zukommt wir
leben in einer welt die ist kleiner
geworden weil sehr viel gereist wird und
dementsprechend ist es umso wichtiger
dass wir das was wir bei der korona
pandemie gelernt haben auch umsetzen
können und an eine sache die wir gelernt
haben ist dass wir mehr
produktionskapazität benötigen und daher
haben wir jetzt hier auch diese
produktionseinheiten gebaut dann eine
letzte frage noch herr sahin sie haben
einen so tollen erfindergeist sie sind
eben unser held der korona krise ist
habe ich vorhin am anfang schon gesagt
dass es wird auch immer so bleiben jetzt
ist corona zumindest wir sind auf einem
guten weg haben sie gerade selber gesagt
das ist eben bald nicht mehr zumindest
das größte problem sein wird aber es
gibt noch ganz viele andere probleme sie
mit ihrem erfindergeist glauben sie dass
sie auch noch einmal andere probleme in
deutschland lösen an oder bleiben sie
bleiben sie in der pharmaindustrie also
wir das was wir können es wirklich
wissenschaft ja und
medikamentenentwicklung und und da
glauben wir auch dass wir einen
unterschied machen machen können und das
ist das worauf wir uns fokussieren es
gibt große probleme medizinische
probleme die ungelöst sind das sind zum
beispiel die krebserkrankung
wo wir wo wir uns erwarten dass
immuntherapien
besonders wenn sie personalisierte
angewandt werden können einen
unterschied bei individuellen patienten
machen können das ist unser traum da
möchten wir weiter weitermachen wir
sehen aber auch die möglichkeiten auf
andere krankheiten unsere unsere
kenntnisse auszuweiten wir arbeiten an
herz-kreislauf-erkrankungen
regenerativen lösungen und und auch
autoimmunerkrankungen das wird jahre
dauern und dementsprechend
dementsprechend müssen wir uns jetzt
nicht unbedingt mit anderen sachen haben
vielen dank für ihre arbeit für ihre
arbeit vor allem jetzt während der
korona krise und jetzt auch für diese
zeit hier bei uns bleibt hin zwischen
damit gebe ich erstmal wieder zurück zu
euch ins studio
ein entscheidenden wichtiges interview
an einem so wichtigen tag und einsatz
ist gefallen der macht ihnen einen
vielleicht das herz auch ein bisschen
leichter ugur sahin der sagt ich sehe
die situation nicht mehr dramatisch und
der auch in aussicht stellt das bis
april spätestens mai ein impfstoff auf
dem markt sein wird gegen omnicom dass
also das interview mit uwe schaar in
unserem in velden